vi ricorderete qualche settimana fa mi
sembra settimana scorsa molti giornali
del mondo sono usciti con grandi titoli
cambiamento climatico siamo prossimi ad
un punto di non ritorno
io vivo in india e anche i giornali
indiani riportavano questa notizia mi è
sembrata una un'introduzione ideale a
quello di cui volevo parlare oggi che
appunto riguarda i cinque grandi
problemi globali di questo pianeta che
sono appunto l'acqua la fame la
malnutrizione la povertà la biodiversità
è appunto il cambiamento climatico
si parla di questi problemi come se
fossero cose indipendenti
in realtà a me piace pensare che sono
tutti in qualche modo collegati e che il
problema dei semi e al centro di questi
problemi il a parlare di sé me significa
fondamentalmente a parlare di salute c'è
stato qualche accenno già quest'oggi
perché tutto il cibo che noi mangiamo di
fatto direttamente o direttamente
proviene da semi e credo che tutti siamo
d'accordo che la nostra salute dipende
da ciò che mangiamo
particolarmente oggi dopo che è stato
dimostrato che molte delle malattie
moderne in realtà derivano dal cibo
tornando al cambiamento climatico
una cosa che non si dice o si dice molto
raramente è che noi in realtà non
sappiamo di cosa parliamo perché nessuno
oggi è in grado di dirvi
quanto più caldo fara è quantomeno
pioverà a como fra 20 anni
associato al problema del cambiamento
climatico c'è quello della biodiversità
appunto
e qui c'è una grande contraddizione
nella scienza moderna perché da una
parte se voi spogliate i numeri delle
riviste più importanti tipo science
national quasi ogni settimana
sicuramente ogni mese ci viene detto che
la biodiversità è la chiave per la
sicurezza alimentare
e dall'altra un altra scienza il
miglioramento genetico che quegli
alimenti produce è andata in maniera
esasperata negli ultimi 20 30 anni verso
l'uniformità in direzione esattamente
opposta
pensate che o dici quello che vuoi
comprare al mercato i cavolfiori le
zucchine i pomodori peperoni
tutta quella roba lì de per essere
legalmente commercializzata quelle
varietà devono essere state iscritte ad
un registro che si chiama appunto
registro delle varietà e per essere
iscritto a quel registro devono essere
uniformi
stabili e riconoscibili e immagino che
la contraddizione tra uniformità e
stabilità e la necessità di adattarsi ai
cambiamenti climatici sia palese
contemporaneamente sempre negli ultimi
20 30 anni forse quaranta si è assistito
gradualmente ad un consolidamento di un
vero e proprio monopolio nel mercato
mondiale dei semi un mercato che vale
miliardi di dollari
e che oggi per il 65 per cento circa è
controllato da quattro grosse
corporazioni
internazionali che cosa significa
controllo del genere significa che
quando l'agricoltore va al mercato a
comprare i semi per seminare non ha
grandissime scelte
negli stati uniti oggi è pressoché
impossibile io ho appena scommesso 50
mila euro è pressoché impossibile
trovare seme di mais o seme di soia che
non sia geneticamente modificato questa
ridotta
possibilità di scelta da parte
dell'agricoltore su ciò che può seminare
si ripercuote sulla diversità di ciò che
il wii coltiva e si ripercuote sulla
diversità del cibo che noi mangiamo e
questo appunto è associato a tutta una
serie di malattie e ci fa pensare se
siamo veramente noi a decidere che cosa
mangiamo
accanto a questo monopolio del mercato
dei semi si è sviluppato un monopolio
nel mercato dei pesticidi cui appunto si
è fatto cenno anche questa mattina i
pesticidi sono delle cose abbastanza
interessanti perché i medici ci dicono
che tra le dodici sostanze chimiche più
pericolose al mondo 9 sono e sicilia
e alcune delle di queste corporazioni
internazionali che vendono segni vendono
anche pesticidi beh allora diventa
logico chiedersi ma se io vendo segni e
tesi cd perché dovrei vendere seme che
danno piante che di pesticidi non hanno
bisogno
e tutto ciò probabilmente finisce in
quel piatto come siamo arrivati a questo
a questo punto
beh
l'evoluzione del miglioramento genetico
di quella scienza cui accennavo prima ci
può aiutare a capire
il primo speaker di questa mattina
parlava appunto della l'uomo del
neolitico 10 12.000 anni fa che a
cominciare dalla mezzaluna fertile quell
arco che va da giordania palestina
israele e siria libano il sud della
turchia e poi giù verso l'iraq
lì è cominciato all'agricoltura io ho
lavorato per trent'anni un istituto
presso vicino ad aleppo e i semi di orzo
più vecchi sono stati trovati in delle
giare in un villaggio a circa 100 km
dalla eletto oggi sommerso dalle acque
del del frate belli l'uomo ha
addomesticato
perché anche le piante possono essere
addomesticate non con i metodi con cui
sia domestico gli animali ma
semplicemente le tante selvatiche
lasciano cadere i semi a terra le piante
diventano addomesticate quando per
mutazioni spontanee trattengono i 6
milioni spiga e la donna probabilmente
del neolitico ha afferrato
immediatamente l'importanza di queste
piante estranei che non lasciavano
cadere i semi a terra e lì in quella
zona
appunto leva mangiare una fertile questo
è successo per il frumento per l'orzo
però lenticchia per il cece per il fico
per il pistacchio e altre specie
questo poi è successo in altre parti del
mondo per altre specie per cosa è
successo che a partire dalle 9 mila anni
fra questa gente ha cominciato a migrare
la turchia la grecia con i balcani sono
entrati in italia dalla frontiera est
circa 7 mila anni fa ea un certo punto
si fermavano e questo lavoro di
miglioramento delle culture e continuato
per circa 9.000 anni e ancora oggi io
l'ho visto in nepal l'ho visto nel nord
dell'india
prima di raccogliere si va al campo si
scelgono le piante più belle quel seme
viene conservato in un angolo fresco e
asciutto della casa quel segue verrà
riseminato l'anno successivo il resto si
raccoglie si mangia o se non ha da
mangiare gli animali
ora immaginatevi
questo lavoro fatto da migliaia di
agricoltori in tantissimi posti del
mondo con tante culture diverse ognuno
ovviamente selezionava per quello che
noi chiamiamo
adattamento specifico cioè selezionava
le tante belle in quel particolare
terreno con quel tipo di pratiche
culturali e per l'uso che faceva di
quella cultura
quando voi sentite parlare di vecchie
varietà di cereali antichi e da questo
lavoro di millenni che vengono
poi alla con la riscoperta delle leggi
di mendel poco più di cento anni fa
il miglioramento di lei ho avuto un
grosso cambiamento nel senso che tutto
ciò che fino a quel punto era stato
fatto da tantissime persone in
tantissimi posti del mondo ha cominciato
ad essere fatto da relativamente poche
persone i ricercatori in relativamente
pochi posti le stazioni di ricerca e c'è
stato un grosso cambiamento di filosofia
della ricerca perché mentre gli
agricoltori
selezionavano trattamento specifico il
ricercatore ovviamente non poteva fare
varietà per la stazione sperimentale le
doveva fare per il mondo esterno e
quindi cercava di selezionare varietà
che andassero bene per quante più
persone possibili
questo ovviamente ha determinato la
scomparsa in parte delle vecchie varietà
ha prodotto una grande uniformità e
soprattutto è una filosofia che è alla
base della cosiddetta agricoltura
industriale che non può fare a meno
della chimica perché queste varietà
ovviamente bene dappertutto non potevano
andare e allora laddove non andavano
bene si modificava l'ambiente con
concimi antiparassitari
pesticidi acqua di irrigazione
in modo che anche quell ambiente per
andare bene per quella varietà questo
per inciso andava bene anche le
industrie sementiere che nel frattempo
stanno sorgendo
perché per l'industria sementiera è
molto più conveniente vendere tanto seme
di poche varietà che poco seme di
tantissime varietà diverse
io ho cercato di ribaltare un po tutto
questo con un metodo di miglioramento
genetico che tulsa cento va facendo
utilizzando la stessa identica scienza
anzi
tutti i requisiti della scienza più
moderna riportava il miglioramento
genetico nelle mani degli agricoltori
questo modello si chiama miglioramento
genetico partecipativo lo sono soltanto
io a farlo è fondamentalmente
introduce tre cambiamenti prima cosa
tutto il lavoro si fa nei cantieri agli
agricoltori di agricoltori partecipano a
tutte le decisioni io quando arrivò
imposto in cui non sono mai stato la
prima domanda che faccio agli
agricoltori e quali sono i vostri
problemi
e
la terza differenza che questo modello
si può applicare in tantissimi villaggi
diversi e sono stato funzioni di quante
risorse voi avete il pallino giallo e
dove io ho lavorato per trent'anni
quelli blu sono le stazioni sperimentali
del ministero della cultura siriano e i
rossi sono i villaggi ecco qui il punto
chiave è che ogni villaggio diventa una
unità di selezione indipendente cioè lì
si seleziona ciò che va bene in quel
villaggio selezionano uomini e donne il
metodo è ovviamente molto inclusivo e si
fanno varietà specificatamente ad a a
quel particolare luogo a quel
particolare modo di di coltivare questo
modello io l'ho cominciato insieme nel
95 poi gradualmente è stato implementato
in marocco in tunisia algeria egitto
etiopia ed eritrea yemen iran e può
arrivare può essere utilizzato in posti
dove il miglioramento genetico
cosiddetto convenzionale non è mai
arrivato questo è un progetto su watson
lenticchia nelle montagne dello yemen
tutta l'agricoltura dello yemen è
praticamente queste terrazze
costruite duemila anni fa
e che non sono mai state raggiunte
appunto dalla scienza convenzionale
poi nella all'incirca intorno al 2007
2008 ci siamo accorti che questo modello
aveva un punto debole
è il punto debole era proprio nella
collaborazione
necessaria di una istituzione
perché le istituzioni nei confronti di
questo modello che di fatto riportava
molto potere nelle mani degli
agricoltori da molti governi in questa
cosa non andava giù per cui nel 2008
io ho rispolverato una vecchia idea di
un ricercatore americano che si chiama
miglioramento genetico evolutivo che
consiste nel fare dei grandi miscugli
questo ne vedete uno coltivato in
sicilia io questa cosa ho cominciato a
fare in siria nel 2008 poi noi siamo
venuti via nel 2011
e questi sono questo è un miscuglio
vi prego di credermi sulla parola di
duemila tipi diversi di frumento tenero
in strumento con cui si fa il pane
che cosa succede che in questo miscuglio
avvengono sempre un po di incroci tra
queste piante per cui il seme che voi
raccogliete non è mai geneticamente
identico a quello che avete seminato
cioè la popolazione gradualmente si
evolve e si evolve in che direzione
nella direzione di e diventare sempre
più adatta adattata a quel particolare
ambiente acqui particolare modo di
coltivare e quindi si adatta bene
l'agricoltura biologica e biodinamica
e soprattutto
se vi ricordate come ho detto all'inizio
sarà adattata al clima che ci sarà tra
vent'anni senza sapere oggi quanto più
caldo fara è quantomeno troverà perché
ha tutto il tempo per appunto evolversi
questa idea in questo momento è attuata
in giordania etiopia in iran a queste
popolazioni stanno diffondendo o
dappertutto e nel 2009 2010 sono
arrivate anche in italia sono tre
popolazioni uno di frumento duro per il
pane una di frumento tenero per la pasta
e uno di orzo solo in questo momento
continuate di circa 14 15 regioni
italiane
gli agricoltori iraniani hanno fatto una
scoperta interessante che adesso stiamo
attuando anche in italia e cioè hanno
fatto il pane direttamente con la farina
di questi miscugli e hanno scoperto che
dopo sei mesi che questo pane stava in
commercio non solo era molto apprezzato
perché aveva un profumo e un aroma
straordinari ma questi panettieri hanno
cominciato a ricevere telefonate dai
clienti che gli dicevano ma che cosa ci
avete messo in quei pane c'è perché
perché in questo villaggio tutti coloro
che soffrivano di tolleranze da quando
hanno cominciato a mangiare quel padre
si sentono molto meglio noi stiamo
facendo ancora questa esperienza in in
italia particolarmente nelle mappe
dove in genere faccio
vado quando vengo in italia e quindi
stiamo dimostrando che con questi i
miscugli non soltanto abbiamo una
tecnologia per adattare le culture in
modo dinamico e poco costoso ai
cambiamenti climatici non solo si
riporta biodiversità dei campi perché
ovviamente queste popolazioni si
evolvono in modo diverso le diversi
posti non solo si riporta il controllo
dei semi nelle mani degli agricoltori ma
si produce cibo
che è molto più diverso e come ho detto
prima diversità di cibo significa
maggiore salute grazie